[Applaudissements]
un an après la légalisation du cannabis
force est d'admettre que le marché noir
n'a pas dit son dernier mot
nous voulons éliminer les profits
d'indiction organisé et ce que nous
faisons
7 octobre 2018 le canada devenait le
premier pays du g20 à légaliser le
cannabis
en tout on parle d'une économie de plus
de 5 milliards de dollars au pays selon
statistique canada
60 % de la consommation se fait toujours
de manière illégale
la société québécoise du cannabis estime
quant à elle que 82 % de l'industrie est
encore aux maîtres du marché noir
on a réussi à convaincre un trafiquant
de drogue la région de montréal de nous
parler de son commerce
je m'en vais le rencontrer mais tout ça
sous le couvert de l'anonymat
le bûcheron l'an dernier à loeb de la
légalisation ils étaient prêts à laisser
tomber son commerce de cannabis semble
si le plan de redéploiement de nos
produits s'ils ne voient pas de
changement dans son chiffre d'affaires
il remarque toutefois une amélioration
de la qualité du canada sur le marché
noir
l'ombre
maintenant si vous le redis peu faveur
des produits que d'ailleurs bien moins
cher que ceux des producteurs autorisées
le prix moyen du cannabis légal est
aujourd'hui de 10,23 dollars le gramme
alors qu'à la même quantité se vend 5,59
dollars sur le marché noir
au cours de la dernière année le
professeur de criminologie à
l'université de montréal david décarie
et hu s'est entretenu avec de nombreux
trafiquants de cannabis
en plus d'étudier les divers marchés du
drac net il observe lui aussi que le
marché noir est toujours dominant cdu
bien souvent en fait en raison de la
fête de distribution du produit légal ça
reste encore aujourd'hui assez difficile
d'aller l'acheter dans des magasins qui
sont encore assez petit en on peut
toujours avoir un marché que ce soit
pour des mineurs pour des gens qui
veulent acheter du cannabis en soirée
sur le territoire québécois on compte
actuellement 22 succursales de la saq
décès un nombre qui devrait passer à 43
6 mars 2020 pour aller chercher le
marché noir
c'est vraiment le prix qui est un
vecteur plus haut la qualité du produit
évidemment puis à l'accessibilité une
proximité
la première année en service de la cud
essai a été marqué par des ruptures de
stocks et par les files d'attentes
devant les commerces
la loi sur le cannabis prévoit
maintenant des peines de prison qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 14 ans pour les
trafiquants alors qu'elle était de 3 ans
maximum avant le 17 octobre 2018 selon
les gens vont être réalisés que
finalement mal le gouvernement
maintenant et rendu un compétiteur si on
veut de la vente du marché noir
j'ai rendez vous dans un motel avec un
vendeur de drogue
ce cas-là tout laisser tomber sa vente
de cannabis pour se concentrer sur
laquelle vous voulez dans les jeux sont
trop ou qu'est-ce que ça votre contenu
chez concentration du marché donc marché
ne veut pas d'enfant par plus de 90
lorsque des drogues en macro donc
rejoint l'ordre ont donc besoin d'un
couple si seulement voilà donc nourrir
son prof de maths a pas de ramallah
avant de la drague qui va rendre les
gens dépendent a cependant voté mais pas
je pense intentions
[Musique]
mais le projet de légalisation est
encore jeune il faudra donc des années
au gouvernement pour vaincre une
économie souterraine qui ne souhaite pas
laisser aller ses profits aussi
facilement
[Musique]